now don't take this the wrong way but
you're a total savage the last thing we
want is to get on your bad side because
you're quick and witty comments would
rip us to shreds you may be the future
queen of auradon but you could give the
queen of mean a run for her money you've
got a silver tongue and are used to
getting the last word we're just happy
that you chose to be good because anyone
who chooses to go up against you gets
what's coming for them deep down mouths
a total softy but don't let that fool
you she can make her enemies crumble
with her words alone she's literally the
queen of the clap back in this video we
go over mouths most savage moments keep
watching to find out which heated
moments snagged the number1 spot now
gives Jane a complex in the first
descendants film Mao uses Jane to get to
fairy godmothers wand she pretends to be
your friend using magic to give her
beautiful hair but then she toys with
Jane's feelings by criticizing her nose
and her other features Jane takes the
bait
leading her to steal her mother's wand
at the end of the movie we know that mal
was just trying to make her mom proud
but her actions made Jane feel ugly and
gave her an inferiority complex cookie
anyone now doesn't need to use magic to
convince people to do things for her
know she can influence someone's
decisions with her words alone in
descendants now bakes a batch of loved
cookies for Ben but when she offers him
one he declines now takes things a step
further by pretending to be hurt
claiming that she wouldn't accept baked
goods from a villain kid either then
immediately feels bad and eats a cookie
proving that mal knows a thing or two
about mind games nice to meet you have
we met no I don't think so
I'm new I'm sort of like a transfer
student
when Malian queen Lea first crossed
paths they're totally amicable Queen Lea
is on her best behavior until Audrey
comes along and changes her tune
Audrey tells her grandma that she
shouldn't be talking to Mel and Lea
freaks out thinking that mal is Vil if
isn't instead of being nice and
explaining that she's not like her mom
Mao pokes the bear she gives her a look
that says don't mess with me Lea snap
out of it now took things a little too
far in descendants when Jay confronted
her about putting a love spell on Ben
Jay was one of the first B Ches to admit
to enjoying life in auradon but mal
wasn't having any of it she was set on
making her mom proud so she did
everything she could to make Jay snap
out of it mal burst Jays bubble by
telling him he was mean awful and bad
news Jay took it well but deep down that
must have hurt you're still shrimpy ooh
my talks a big talk but deep down she
just wants to be accepted Nala Numa used
to be best friends until Mao betrayed
her and made her the laughingstock of
the Isle
uma hates being called shrimpy and mal
knows it and uses it against her in
descendants - malli Numa arm-wrestled to
decide Ben's fate and mal delivers a low
blow against Yuma to try and win the
match this has got to be one of Mao's
most savage moments long time no see
Gary hook and mal have a lot of
chemistry and descendants too when they
run into each other at the curl up and
die salon mal immediately gives Harry
some serious attitude she takes things a
step further when she sticks a piece of
chewed up gum on the plain of Harry's
hook most people would see this as a
huge insult but Harry loved it let's be
smart when it comes to insulting uma now
is a total champ in descendants - Ben
gets kidnapped by uma and her pirates
and mal tries to strike a deal with uma
to save him but instead of being nice
mal delivers yet another low blow
she basically calls uma stupid claiming
that being smart is hard for her this
insult came flying out of mouths mouth
like it was no big deal
now laughs in Audrey's face mal is so
used to calling the shots that being the
one on the receiving end is super new to
her so when Audrey comes for a mile in
descendants three she totally laughs in
her face word to the wise laughing in
someone's face when they're holding
Maleficent sceptre isn't the smartest
thing to do but mal just couldn't help
herself now gets personal with Hades hi
dad one of the best songs of descendant
three has got to be do what you gotta do
it's fun and catchy and loaded with
hilarious lines now has a full-on savage
moment when singing with her dad who she
knows has had a tough time adjusting to
life on the Isle but when mal gets angry
she tells Hades that she's not as sad as
him without his powers
yikes she went straight for the knockout
now lies to everyone but if there's one
time I went way too far it's when she
lied to everyone about closing down the
barrier for good the kids won't be
coming off the PIO what do you mean
mal was determined to save Oregon so she
told Emma that she would let the BK's
cross the barrier thankfully mal pulled
through in the end who would you rather
be best friends with mal easier uma
sound off in the comments and that's a
wrap
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching we'll see you
again soon
you
[Music]